hey guys I'm Eric mark I'm Kyle for Bach
and this is an in-depth breakdown of the
newest rogue one trailer so Philip and I
did the other road one video where we
kind of really went into all the
characters and stuff but in this one
we're like just digging in going through
the plot and stuff because we think we
solved this we think we don't yeah yeah
so in this video we're gonna make some
predictions based off of what we've seen
in this trailer and what we've seen in
the first teaser along with the recent
Star Wars Celebration footage and the
international version of the trailer and
assuming that these predictions are
completely correct and we're as smart as
we think we are huge spoiler warning for
everything you're about to see but um
let's get started yeah the world is
coming undone Imperial flags rain across
the galaxy okay so first we get this
opening aerial shot of jet ha that's a
new place in the Star Wars universe it's
a small desert moon that's very cold and
covered in frost and that's why probably
that we're seeing people wearing these
heavy coats later in the trailer no this
place Jedi is actually super important
it's a new place as we said but it's
actually a really really old place it's
actually the first place people started
experimenting with using the force hence
the name Jedi and the name Jedi sounding
very similar coincidence no that's why
this place is kind of like a spiritual
mecca Holy Land kind of like Jerusalem
for people who are dedicated to the
force so we got this giant pyramid thing
looking over here that looks like the
Jedi Temple on Coruscant this place
seems like where everyone packed up and
went to after the Jedi Temple was sacked
in Revenge of the Sith and Jedi became
kind of outlawed they all went to this
place and started worshiping what we say
in the other video is the Church of the
force and then clearly this place is
under occupation by the Empire you can
see imperial landers TIE fighters
hovering over the director this movie
Gareth Edwards said and interviews that
the Empire is looking for something
special that serves both the Empire and
the rebels and of course during the Star
Wars Celebration we got confirmation
that this is Highberger so that's not
the cool thing to say like Kyber
crystals
it's like a pop drink yeah those are the
crystals that the Sith and the Jedi used
to make their lightsabers they actually
also the thing that powers the Death
Star's super laser so that is completely
what its gonna be used for in this movie
no doubt okay so over all this we're
hearing jyn erso talking with saw
Guerrera that's Forest Whitaker's
character we go way into this guy in our
other video so definitely check that out
but his hair is completely different
than what we saw before so our
prediction there's two different things
here either from the celebration footage
we know Jin is at some point is a little
girl miss so this might be him talking
to her when she is a little girl so she
he doesn't have the beard or anything
yeah he's just like young and fly and
then later when she meets up with him on
Jedi he's kind of let himself go or
another way this could go is that these
different looks aren't from a flashback
this could be that same kind of scenario
with Jen trying to recruit this old
grizzled war veteran except she actually
convinces them and then we get the
sequence where you know cleans up and
he's shady tries on different outfits
and she's like you know like this 80s
music is playing like looking at me and
then he comes out and it's like battle
worn armor and she's like I like it yeah
putting on some Will Smith sunglasses
like I make this look good
that's an initial prediction yeah but
real quick before we move on there's
some double meanings of what saw says
here Imperial flags bring across the
galaxy so this could very literally mean
the Empire rules the galaxy but as we
see in this shot here there is a giant
Star Destroyer like floating like a rain
cloud over the city on jet hot so you
got that double meaning layer also be
kind of a theory that the Death Star
might be affecting the atmosphere
conditions on this planet so rain might
have another we literally see rain later
so they constructed the entire movie
around the word rain that's my
prediction let's move on can you be
trusted without your shackles let's just
get this over with shall we
with a mission for you
a major weapons test is imminent we need
to know how to destroy next section
shows a lot of what we already saw in
the first trailer so there's only just a
couple things that we want to point out
first is captain kassian and/or here
he's a rebel recruiter they talked about
him in the other video but check out
this look that he's giving Jesse on cuff
sir that's like a serious stink eye
right there we also got this shot where
she's given him a look but just a couple
seconds later they're in the cockpit of
a Ewing and they seem to be best friends
alright it seems like they line it out
yeah something happened where they just
went each other over and they're best
friends now you're really doing this I
want to help good
good what we're thinking is that she was
captured and brought to them for the
specific reason of hey being part of our
Suicide Squad on this special mission
and why in particular do they want
Jenner so well the international version
of this trailer actually gives us even
more information so check it out
we have intercepted a coded Imperial
transmission it indicates that a major
weapons test is imminent the message was
sent by your father Mads Mikkelsen will
be playing Jin's father gallon or so I'm
pretty sure that's what we see in the
celebration footage where you got all
those dudes coming across the field
which who we say in our other video is
orson chronic and all the white yeah so
in based on all this stuff let's just
make another prediction here so from
attack of the clones we know that the
empire already has plans to make the
Death Star and in Revenge of the Sith we
see just the outline of the Death Star
and then checking it out yeah so this
movie takes place immediately before the
battle station becomes fully operational
and we know they're testing the super
laser
I think gallon or so is the dude who
figures out that Kyber crystals can
power a super laser because we know
that's what powers it and the empire is
like we got to get this guy to make our
super laser we see that shot of the
super laser dome being put onto the
Death Star it's a big deal about that
the whole movie seems to be about will
the Death Star shoot its laser and I
think this guy is what facilitates all
of this to happen yeah and meanwhile
when they take down or so Ginn escapes
and grows up to be this rogue criminal
and I think the rebels believe that gen
is the only one who can find a father to
retrieve the Death Star blueprints so
that they can destroy it yeah I think
you know I think that's why cassian is
totally on board with the suicide
mission he's like damn your life seems
bad so far and I want to see if I could
help you out yes
also it would actually fit with the Star
Wars track record of pulling from
history so like after World War 2 when
Soviet Union was rising to power they
basically forced all the top scientist
from Eastern Europe to help them build
these weapons of mass destruction just
like the Death Star's weapon mass
destruction literally and many of these
scientists actually defected and leaked
secrets to the United States just like
gallon or so is apparently doing by
leaking information to the rebellion we
actually talked about that in our other
video our character breakdown because it
very literally translates to a thing
with history gallon or so is actually
compared to
scientist it's super interesting but
before we move on there's one more thing
that was confirmed at celebration that
Jimmy Smits is returning as Bail Organa
he's making a small cameo but I think
he's gonna be in that like situation
room thing that's going on and I think
he's gonna be the person who goes okay
we got Revenge of the Sith this movie
and how this moves on to become a new
hope I think he's gonna be that
connective tissue all right let's move
on are you really doing this
I want to help good
good
I've been recruiting through the
rebellion for a long time we destroyed
uh-oh looks like gin was intended to go
on this mission alone are you really
doing this I want to help which is kind
of weird that they're like hey you girl
who's notorious for being a rebel be the
only person we're kind of hanging this
entire thing on but I guess that's what
Kassian feels when he decides to go with
her you know yeah and that just shows us
how much of a suicide mission this is
for the rebellion they don't want to
expend any of their soldiers as far as
we know though everyone in this thing
dies except Darth Vader because we know
Darth Vader is a guy still but everyone
else could be dead unless we have
another released version of the original
trilogy with more force ghosts at the
end of Return of the Jedi I don't give
George Lucas admission so uh the ship
that they take off in is a you wink you
know what reminds me of like the Cylon
ships from Battlestar Galactica it has
wings out in front of it and cool though
it's like a transport ship it's not like
an x-wing like a fighter thing like as
you see later on they're like kind of
hunched down in this thing like it looks
like you could transport troops or
something in it if you look inside these
yellow radar screens and analog controls
it's all very reminiscent of the
original Star Wars movies and force
awakens so it feels like rogue one is
really going to feel part of this world
drink every time you hear the word
practical effects between now and the
time this movie comes out and you'll die
so this section here shows is one of the
battle scenes which takes place on this
like rocky canyon terrain during a
nighttime rainstorm I think we see Bay's
we see cheer it and they're firing down
on a bunch of stormtroopers and we see
Bay's say destroyed uh-oh which kinda
reminds me this is a deep cut remember
for salacious from ahead the guy named
Kasdan paratus who when you fought the
boss battle he would just go you're
ruining my home
ruining uh-oh you know not diner huh
don't you think my friends and I always
say whenever we come over like knock
over drinks you're ruining my home
I hope someone out there feels a
connection to this now you may be
wondering uh this whole scene how does
it fit in the overall storyline now
there's a couple different theories but
let's go ahead and make a prediction
here I think that this scene could be
take place on Jetta
in the first half of the movie at an
empire mining facility for Kyber
crystals so after cheer it kicks ass and
rescues Jen and cassia from storm
troopers which we see at other parts of
this trailer they team up and they tried
to prevent the Empire from acquiring the
crystals to power the Death Star's super
laser but just like any time an imperial
force drills for a precious substance
underneath a spiritual Holy Land
like an avatar oh you know the Middle
East mmm a local impulsively acts out
saying you're ruining our home and I
think this part of the mission fails
so yeah the celebration footage actually
shows Jin landing in the rain and
getting blown back whoa it looks like a
ship's engines looking like the empire
escapes she gets left behind they get
the crystals just my theory I think
you're wrong there oh and I'm gonna tell
you why later let's move on yeah
my idea I'm tired
I fear nothing all this as the force
will see
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
Thanks so check this out there's a shot
of the Ewing flying passes plateau and
Jetta and if you look closely to the
left over here if you kind of like
there's something that looks like it
could be a guy or girl or a person or
rock but I think I think it's a person
like right I feel like if we like zoom
in really hard just like enhance and
adds enhance and just going all the way
yeah I think we could see a guy that
we're like just like a Ben Kenobi doing
like the crate Dragon things like so is
it a dude watching them is it maybe saw
agrerro
living in a cave and watching them land
on the planet or is it a rock we'll find
out
we also get a better look at that big
hairy armed creature on Jenna and now we
see that it also has robotic legs and no
head so the celebration footage even
showed us that they intentionally
removed the head and post so seriously
cool what the hell is I hope that guy
knew that was gonna be as a role right
he's not like this is my big break mom
look who I face it's like he looks like
one of SIDS toys from Toy Story yeah so
we'll see what happens to this guy maybe
hole decapitate a stormtrooper and just
put the stormtroopers head on his
shoulder a couple things to point out
about cheering here he's blind he's a
blind guy but he is just destroying
everyone but the interesting thing is he
doesn't have the force and confirmed
that he is not for sensitive he just
really believes in what we in the other
video talk about is the Church of the
force or just you know spiritually
believing in the forest he says a line
in the trailer saying I fear nothing and
as we all know that is part of the whole
Jedi path here is the path to the dark
side here leads to anger anger leads to
hate hate leads to suffering I guess
even though you're not force sensitive
just believing in the force a lot could
turn you into Matt Murdock right and we
also see you k2a so here the captain
says you are a friend I will not kill
you
Thanks it feels like based on this line
that this is the first time their median
so we're thinking that everything we see
on Jetta might happen early in the movie
with everything else happens after might
be weird to say like after knowing
someone for longer yeah for like an hour
of a movie don't yeah let's move on
there isn't much time every day they
grow stronger okay so this section right
here is the most visually awesome part
of the trailer the Death Star is
freaking upside down over the planet
which blew everyone's minds because the
Death Star can go upside down yes it's
outer space and it actually makes more
sense cuz we have the super laser
actually aiming at the target here it's
a really cool shot and right here we see
this awesome freaking shot of the Death
Star eclipsing the Sun so in this case
this time it actually is a moon right
it's a moon prissom guys look look at my
large Space Station guys like that's no
large Space Station that's a moon and
real quick I want to point out how well
this trailer gives us a sense of scale
now Phillip talked about this a lot in
the last trailer and this trailer in
particular gives us seven shots that
when you put them in order back-to-back
this comparative positioning shows us
exactly what size everything is so I'm
just gonna fly through these real fast
so first there's that opening shot of
the city on Jetta and you can see the
Star Destroyer shadow looming over the
city it's not even in frame yet cuz it's
too big second there's a prospective
shot of gin and casseon looking up at
the plateau with the destroyer hovering
over it all in frame looking massive
third there's a more detailed shot of
the Destroyers hull as it comes into the
light for that shot pulls back to show
the Destroyer passing in front of the
shadow line on the surface of the Death
Star v that shot pulls out into a wider
shot of the destroyer looking tiny
compared to the Death Star as a focus
lens is lowered in six the death star
orbits upside down on Jetta like a kid
using this massive space station is just
like a tiny toy and seventh the Eclipse
shot making the Death Star so large it
literally blocks out the light and yeah
if you are familiar with gareth edwards
work on movies like godzilla you know
that scale is really his signature move
if you know what I mean let's move on
okay
every day they grow stronger Lucy
Orson Critic showing up in the Death
Star we hear the firing sound it's over
jet on doesn't sound like jet I was
gonna have a good time right now kind of
like with Alderaan in a new hope that
they test out the Death Star on jet ha
and because it's not fully operational
yet like we see in a new hope it just
really puts a big ol hole in it but
doesn't blow it up you know what I mean
yeah but it might have even more
emotional weight than the destruction of
Alderaan does because they're
establishing Jeddah as like the
spiritual homeland of the force and all
the Jedi so seeing that wiped out is
such a huge blow to the rebellion
emotionally so let's put all this
together the version of this story that
seems to be the most likely version to
us first we see Mon Mothma telling jyn
erso to find your father so that they
could destroy the Death Star then we
have Jan and Cassy and traveling from
Yemen to Jeddah to find Sagar era the
old family friend to help find Galen or
so here we got Bey's and sherek popping
up they're gonna try to stop the Empire
from getting the Kyber crystals on
Jeddah and that's where they all team up
maybe this is where Bodi rook comes to
play because we know he's actually from
Jeddah huh maybe helps him get off the
planet and whatever they're trying to do
they bail and the Empire gets the
crystals and uses them to destroy the
sacred Jedi Holy Land okay if you're
still with us this is where we're less
sure about what happens for the rest of
the trailer here yeah it kind of gets
harder to predict based on the footage
what order everything comes in but you
know what we're in this together let's
keep going
there was a ninety-seven point six
percent chance of failure
in me as well so in this section we see
shots of the battle scene on scurry
that's the new tropical planet where a
major battle takes place in rogue one
and based on the charging rebel soldiers
and the x-wing flying overhead this
seems like a coordinated rebel strike
not just some last-ditch effort by Jen
and her crew you can actually see what
looks like the Ewing on fire and if
that's the same Ewing that would mean
all this happens after the other events
of the story possibly the second or
third act so why is this battle
happening is the question here's what we
know about scurry we see the death star
plans starting on Gino's is an attack of
the clones and then construction of the
Death Star's move to scurry to
accommodate the resources the Empire
requires which makes sense because if I
were gonna build a giant you know death
moon thing it might be like I want to
have some drinks on the beach and make
my my super weapon so if the Empire is
building the Death Star in this planet
it would make sense that the blueprints
would be lying around somewhere
also other shots are shown this tall
satellite looking structure and we know
that there is a shield generator on
screen and this satellite could be that
shield generator it kind of looks like
the one from Return of the Jedi on Endor
that was protecting the second Death
Star as it was being constructed so I
think it's safe to make the prediction
that there's this giant underground
Imperial base on scurry if we've seen
footage that kind of was shot in that
train station I think who's in London
yeah we've seen other stuff of Jin
seemingly doing like a cute little heist
costume thing you know what I mean the
fun part of the heist words like they're
in silly costumes and lives aren't on
the line right drags the person in the
closet comes out wearing exactly what
this yeah I got a second later we have
that part that I'm thinking takes place
in here in the beginning of this heist
thing maybe this battle is taking place
outside of the base to draw everyone's
attention out of there like a diversion
right or you know honestly the other
thing it could be is we have these shots
of gin running with what looks like a
hard drive on there maybe that's the
blueprints and maybe this whole battle
only happens on the way out like a
rescue mission you know what I mean cuz
it could easily be a thing that they
went in there covert and then they got
discovered and then it's like oh [ __ ]
send in the cavalry yeah another thing
that makes us think this happening kind
of the same
as we see these tan armored shore
troopers running around we're also
seeing a few quick shots of that battle
that's taking place on jet ha with Jan
and the storm trooper this could be
where bays and cheer 'it's show up
because we see gin and casseon in
shackles earlier on maybe they're saved
by bays and shear it maybe that's how
they all get together in the first place
yeah if you look closely the balcony of
this building that gets hit by the tank
fire that looks like there's a person up
there and you'd remember in the first
trailer there's an over-the-shoulder
shot of someone triggering like a
roadside bomb this could be saw Guerrera
like we said in our other video he kind
of does a lot of terrorists kind of
things when he fights that's why the
rebels are kind of feeling a little
weird about having him on our side right
right so this could easily be a kind of
improvised explosive device that he's
using on and this could be the way he
dies if he dies we don't really see him
in the rest of the movie it kind of
seems like his whole story just takes
place on Jenna in that opening or maybe
he got a third haircut and we had my
cousin for that reason yeah maybe he's
the headless big boss's head obviously
just take a little off the top no I got
it okay so we see another shot of this
Imperial Lander exploding that we saw in
the other trailer but based off of what
we saw on the celebration footage this
explosion is just huge so enormous yeah
so I don't know if this is just someone
shooting at this or maybe someone set
off some explosives to go off inside we
don't really know we also don't know if
it's taking off or landed right it could
be reinforcements or it could be them
trying to get out of there and they're
getting shot at on the way out right
right and before we move on this is
where we get our first shot of Bodie
rook we talk about him a lot in our
other character-based video but my guess
is this is the team halfway through the
movie after they leave Jedi before or
maybe during this battle he seems a
little apprehensive about whatever is
about to happen the way this is cut it
makes it seem like he's having second
thoughts about trying to fight the
entire empire but let's keep going
this is a chance to make real difference
so here we see a shot of x-wing swooping
in on that nighttime rain battle that we
talked about before so if this is part
of that Kyber crystal battle on jet Hawk
it's going to be a pretty major aerial
battle we see a TIE fighter fly into
regular thing kind of force awakens
style honestly so this just can be a
real messy battle if it is the Kyber
crystals you know it's gonna be defended
like crazy cuz they're like kind of all
of their eggs are in that basket right a
bunch of people trying to take those egg
we also see BAE's shoot a rocket
launcher at an 80 a CT which is kind of
like an 80 80 but it says for all
terrain armored cargo transport so
that's for carrying people and/or things
so that's a new thing it looks the same
but I guess you put different things on
the inside yeah if they're building the
Death Star on this planet it would help
to have something that can like
transport huge girders and beams it's
just the dopest bus on this planet but
that rocket launcher could be what Jiang
wen was referring to in the celebration
panel when he said is a huge yawn right
before he spoiled a major character
death so if you are brave you could find
that on the internet I watch it it is
honestly one of the most painful things
I've ever seen
you see I'm not gonna say anything but
you see the people all around him
reacting like oh my god I can't believe
you just said that it is it is honestly
I feel a deep physical pain when I watch
it but if you want to know the
informations out there let's move on
are you with me
all the way
so here we see these epic shots of the
Jetta plateau being destroyed and just a
few things to point out here notice how
casseon jumps in hyperspace from within
the planet's atmosphere that's huge that
is huge remember in the force awakens
jumping from hyperspace in to a plants
atmosphere was like super dangerous but
the only way to escape is collapsing
rock and rubble is to just hastily jump
in hyperspace from the current position
this shot is actually really cool if you
notice in all the other Star Wars movies
when they jump to hyperspace they're
focusing on the space but in this one
they're focusing on the characters with
the hyperspace jump in the background
and it's cool cuz Gareth Edwards is
keeping the focus on the characters in
this also I love that k2s o is sitting
in the front seat here well Jin just
kind of scrambles around in the back I
guess robots can call Shotgun yeah yeah
we talked about that in our other video
what is their relationship but I just
seems like a han and chewie thing is
going on right here and if you look
closely at the city as we're being
destroyed you'll notice what looks kinda
like lightning bolts from within the
cloud of rubble earlier you're talking
about the rain battle taking place
before the Death Star fired but I think
it's taking place after I think the
Death Star messes up the atmosphere
causes it to rain [ __ ] hits the fan and
there they are fighting in the rain all
that rain stuff takes place maybe like a
last-ditch effort to get the Kyber
crystals kind of like fu to the empire
and that would make sense why bassist
destroyed uh-oh is he talking about how
his city was wiped out absolutely yeah
okay let's talk about this shot of gin
up here on this catwalk with this Thai
fighter
there's a couple of possibilities here
maybe she is super confident that she's
gonna take out this Thai fighter maybe
she's like really focused on whatever
that thing is at the end of here or
maybe it's a thing we're like the thing
opens it's kind of like return to the
Jedi where Chewie comes out of top the
United States like maybe that happens
here Chewie shows I'm gonna be insane so
how does this shot fit in with the
overall story again very hard to predict
and there's a lot of ways that can go
but I feel like there's two ways that
we've narrowed it down to so either this
big screech battle is the big 3rd act
finale of the movie the rebels kicking
ass on the circus gate with the thing
and they just walk off the planet and
hand it to Princess Leia
yeah no hope or or this whole section is
just the middle of the movie we do see a
lot of shots of gin
and cassia in costume hi earlier said
that maybe this is them part of the
heist you know like the fun little
wheeling them in like a cart kind of
part of Ocean's eleven or maybe this is
a big third act
oh [ __ ] scenario words like we gotta go
into the Death Star maybe trying to save
her dad you know yeah
this could be the moment where they go
rogue to pay service to the title the
movie they became the rogue - I hate
myself my point being that gin and
casseon both go into this thing part of
me thinks that she goes everyone go on
without me I have to get my dad and
Cassie is like yo homie I told you I was
in it to win it and they both go kind of
thing that would make sense for
character art stuff they had their
differences at first but they learned
that they could die together you can
imagine that the studio gonna hold off
from showing us this stuff because it
sounds like a really fun awesome part of
the movie and this is the part where it
is revealed that they're Rey's parents
[Music]
soledad we're pretty nuts man yeah and
while we're on the subject in the
international trailer gin actually says
this line may the force be with us
and considering gin doesn't really seem
like a spiritual person it kind of feels
like when Han Solo said that line to
Luke in a new hope right before the
final charge of the Death Star hey Luke
may the force be with you so if this
line comes at the end of this grief
battle it could be like a push into the
final act of them yeah just like Anna
knew yeah it could be like here is my
character arc coming to a conclusion
which leads us to the final part here
the big reveal with this trailer is will
Papa Skywalker's in this that's what I
like the column Papa's got papa
Skywalker Darth Vader is in rogue one
now we don't know how much he is in this
movie but there are rumors on the
internet that concepts are made for the
movie is super duper freakin violent on
Vader's behalf there's rebels getting
chopped in half used as human shields in
a battle environment similar to what
we're seeing on screen so for all we
know
Vader gets down and dirty in this battle
I also saw some stuff that was just
people hoping that I thought was dope
which is in the last part of the movie
where gin and casseon are in the Death
Star is kind of like a monster movie
with them and Darth Vader chasing that
would be freaking insane and again this
is all just like what artists wanted to
be in this movie so if you imagine
you're a concept artist working on a
Star Wars movie what version of Darth
Vader would you want to see this is what
we've heard so far we'll see how much
Disney allows to be in this movie
because you know they're trying to make
a movie that's it appeals to kids they
shops Darth Maul in half yeah and all
fairness and anakin got lit on fire was
like oh hey so it could be violent it
could not be but this is the part we
have never seen Darth Vader in his prime
we saw him as Anakin kicking ass we see
him as Darth Vader and we're told yo
that guy's scary but we don't see him in
the suit right being the thing that were
terrified on yeah so this would be the
movie to fulfill all of our wishes from
the past 40 years right
a 40-year old man right so cool that's
that's it that's everything we have for
this new rogue one trailer all the
predictions we made and yes I haven't
pointed out yet I know I'm wearing
glasses and I don't normally wear
glasses I seriously just ran out of
contacts and we wanted something to
distinguish too but cool thank you guys
so much for watching if you like this
video please subscribe to our Channel
and just make sure to like it and if you
really liked it share it with your
friends that's one way you can help this
channel is by getting the word out but
you can also support us on patreon thank
you so much to all of our current
patrons on patreon you guys are awesome
your reason we're able to get these
videos out so fast so please continue
giving and you guys are awesome we love
you and you can follow us on Twitter
here's his here's mine
yeah and you can also follow the new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
with any questions about winner and
future videos are gonna be coming out
and really quick if you want a shirt
like this or things like this it's from
loot crate so hit up loot crate loot
crate comm slash rock stars and use the
code rockstars and get 10% off and you
get stuff like this it's cool let's go
watch this 400 more times like we did
while writing this video
[Music]
I wish you Phillip would let us out of
here I never want to leave